est ce que vous diriez en tant que
responsable de la banque de france pour
le département du doubs que la situation
des entreprises s'améliore fin d'année
2010 est et en ce début d'année 2010 8
oui tout à fait une amélioration de la
situation des entreprises notamment
chiffre d'affaires également rentabilité
même si c'est un peu moins vrai et
particulièrement dans l'industrie
beaucoup dans les services enfin ça
continue toujours être assez bons dans
le transport aussi oui beaucoup plus tôt
des éléments positifs le vert est à peu
près partout
est ce que les investissements c'est
quand magna indicateur important est ce
que les investissements sont fort en
cette année 2010 est et sont prévues à
la hausse en deux temps les
investissements étaient assez rare dans
les années précédentes en 2017 a déjà eu
une évolution positive de
l'investissement et lés prévisions donc
qui doivent être évidemment vérifier
dans le temps mais en 2018 sont
nettement à la hausse en matière
d'investissements notamment industriels
est ce que l'on peut dire que c'est le
secteur automobile qui tire l'économie
en franche comté
j'allais dire comme d'habitude c'était
en effet un secteur essentiel pour la
franche comté
l'anc l'automobile
et toutes les entreprises qui tournent
autour de l'automobile donc évidemment
la grande entreprise automobile de la
franche comté et puis également les sous
traitants qui sont dans la métallurgie
très souvent qu'ils peuvent être
éventuellement la plasturgie et qui
apporte beaucoup d'activités
pour le secteur automobile voilà y
compris à l'étranger d'ailleurs oui
l'exportation d'ailleurs a plutôt bien
marché l'année passée et pour 2018 les
chefs d'entreprise prévoient d'ailleurs
davantage d'exportations c'est un bon
signe parce que c'est vrai qu'il ya les
entreprises automobiles françaises mais
également nos partenaires européens en
particulier les allemands qui sont
intéressés par l'activité de
sous-traitance qui existent dans le
département du doubs et dans la franche
comté est ce que le seul point j'allais
dire un peu négatif le seul bémol c'est
l'emploi les effectifs
les entreprises investissent mais n'en
bouge pas alors c'est tout à fait vrai
alors il peut y avoir plusieurs raisons
la non embauche première c'est que c'est
difficile d'embaucher difficile d'avoir
des gens qui soient suffisamment
qualifiés pour ces activités qui sont de
plus en plus pointues la deuxième chose
aussi c'est que les entreprises n'ont
peut-être pas suffisamment investi les
années précédentes elles sont
aujourd'hui en phase d'investissement ça
coûte assez cher elles vont robotisée
davantage avant des investissements plus
productifs plus développés et à ce
moment là elles sont plutôt dans une
phase d'investissement il est possible
qu après l embauche un peu plus mais
c'est quand même déjà les
investissements industriels et de
productivité qui vont qui ce qui se
développe en ce moment c'est certain